the jurogan experience
i wanted to have you on first of all
because i really respected that you made
this change of opinion publicly
when you were first talking about
marijuana
you were talking about it as if it had
no medical benefit and it was really
just a recreational drug that was
possibly or probably harmful is that a
assessment that you agree with i i think
it certainly didn't seem to have any
medicinal benefits right yeah but then
upon further examination
you
publicly changed your position
and and
you in in doing so you actually examined
all the scientific evidence that pointed
to for many people with diseases many
people that are on chemotherapy
many people with
you know some serious ailments marijuana
can be very beneficial and you talked
about that and i really admired that
because that takes a lot of courage
because a lot of people
when they uh have an idea and they
proclaim it publicly they double down
and they just they you know use
confirmation bias and whatever you know
echo chamber news sources they can get
to sort of confirm their initial
position and you didn't do that and i i
thought that's a real
a real thinking person
who is trying to
[Music]
honestly figure out what's going on
instead of just working on being right
well i look i i appreciate that and
i have been very it was very
illuminating for me because i think the
way that we
become a more knowledgeable society i
think sometimes surprises people um
i do think and maybe this will dovetail
even to a little bit of what's going on
now but but the thing is that
when you looked at the so if you were
just to look at the
bulk of evidence around
cannabis at that and i'm talking i wrote
this time magazine article back you know
this is probably 12 13 years ago and i
looked at the bulk of evidence and you
say okay i'm going to look at the 400
most recent papers i'm going to read the
abstracts i'm going to dig in deep on
some of them
and 94 of them were basically the
hypothesis was
where's the harm here show me the harm
right the hypothesis was not show me the
benefit that was only true for about six
percent so right away you're dealing
with a sort of very biased sort of set
of data and that's one stream up now if
you're just looking at papers you're
like well this one potentially long harm
this one possible addiction this one
gateway you know you're seeing all those
individual studies but at a broader
level one step upstream you realize that
most of the studies that are getting
funded
are designed to look for harm right yeah
so when i saw that that was the first
time i thought why why are the studies
that are getting out there why are they
all designed to look for harm
then i started looking in other
countries and some really good research
out of places like israel in particular
a guy named raf mushulum who's 91 years
old now he's the first guy to ever
isolate thc and then synthesize it he's
been doing this work forever he may get
the nobel prize before he dies for for
his work in this
they were talking about the use of
cannabis for all sorts of ailments
including
refractory seizures in kids um
and that one really that really got to
me for a couple reasons one is that
i think when you're trying to do studies
on things like pain
it's it's hard it's a subjective thing
right and so you think is is how do you
how do you really have conclusive proof
that this is working the way that you
think it is someone says their pain is
better and that's important but how do
you measure that a little child who's
having 300 seizures a week and is now
not having seizures is a much more
specific sort of metric
and
it it seemed to work really well in in
kids who did not respond to existing
seizure drugs
which was kind of amazing to me and i
think i told you when we've spoken
before that that
to me in some ways that wasn't just a a
medical issue at that point it was a
moral issue because nothing worked for
these kids
and they were thinking about even
compounding veterinary medications for
them and these parents are like you know
in their kitchen things stirring up you
know cannabis trying to get the
formulation right to turn it into an oil
or a tincture they could put underneath
the kid's tongue and
and it was working and you know i did
stories on these kids and they were
emblematic of thousands of more kids
these weren't just anecdotal stories
and that's when i said you know there's
something here but i gotta tell you um
when i wrote the article saying i
changed my mind on this
you know
you know you hit send at night and then
you wake up in the morning and
i work at a university
i'm a i'm a practicing physician you
know i live in that world and part of me
did wonder like what is the response
going to be i felt very comfortable with
what i had written what i did not know
was how it would be received yeah and
that and that's that's always a
challenge i think how was it received
i think well i'm still employed so that
that part of it was good you know i i
didn't know if my chairman would say hey
look you know uh
i may agree or not agree with you that's
beside the point you shouldn't have done
this or whatever i i you know i had no
idea how they were going to respond
i think it was received well joe i think
that um it added to the knowledge tree
of how we advance as a society it's a
sign of the times i think i think if you
had done that a couple of decades ago
maybe there have been a lot more
pushback i think people are coming to
much more of an understanding and and
also the logical
aspect of it like when when people look
at all the things that human beings are
allowed to consume including this uh
that you gave me here this looks
it's pretty spectacular i'm pretty proud
of my gift that i've given you some
serious bourbon here well thank you for
that for the man who has everything this
is um
legal you know i mean we can enjoy the
glass it's normal it's it's a normal
thing and we all agree to that it's it's
a
you know it's a long-standing tradition
for people to drink alcohol socially
marijuana
for whatever reasons and we could go
into that if you want but it's been
demonized
unfairly and people know that it's not
like heroin or crack or things that
you've seen people's lives fall apart on
it on a regular basis and i think most
people are aware of that now so in the
era that you publish that
it's people have come to an
understanding that it's not
it's not one of the hard drugs it's not
the most dangerous thing in the world
it's not good for kids it's not good for
some people it's not good for some
people maybe with uh possible
schizophrenic tendencies
i think there's a real concern there and
uh
no i i mean yeah i you know it's it you
you raise a really important point you
know one thing i tried to stay away from
whenever i wrote about this was
i felt like was a little bit of a trap
to get into the moral equivalency of
things
like i think things should just stand on
their own two feet you know well it's
better than this right
what you're saying is true i feel like
alcohol can be a sledgehammer to the
brain i really do if you think about the
way alcohol affects the brain very
different than the way cannabis affects
the brain
um and
that that part of it is true but the
idea
that it could be a medicine in
particular i mean you know i i think
that that that is really
quite striking and it's a plant you know
and there's all these things and i
listen like i said i listen to your
podcast i listen to brett and i listen
to others and i get the points that
they're making about that in terms of
can you look to the earth to heal and
oftentimes you can you know we've been
given a lot of things but i think that
with with cannabis in particular
the the the evidence
i'm not the first to say this obviously
people have been saying this for a long
time maybe the timing was right but two
decades ago people were saying this
three decades ago people were saying
this this was on the formulary in the
united states in the 1940s post-river
reefer madness which i think was like
1936 or something like that people were
already saying hey wait a second
this could be used to treat addiction
this could be used to treat you know
even
parkinsonian-like symptoms there was all
these things that they were putting out
there and then it went through this
cultural sort of assassination for a
while which was which was wild to sort
of reflect on historically watch the
entire episode for free only on spotify